hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my fear The Walking Dead episode 4
video so next week is actually called
cobalt and that was the working title of
fear The Walking Dead before they
started calling it fear The Walking Dead
so this is really when things are
starting to get crazy just give up for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet a new round of the giveaway starts
now all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so here we go starting with top 5
WTF moments number 5 welcome to the safe
zone nothing to see here move it along
just keep moving along don't mind the
bodies outside so charting the time line
it's been nine days since they put up a
fence around what is now being called
the safe zone and there are 12 of these
12 different safe zones in addition to
quote-unquote quarantine zones that we
haven't seen yet the other safe zones
probably just look like this safe zone
beyond the military we really don't know
who else is in charge it just seems like
it's military rule right now the
lieutenant there has gone full-on mash
he's just like hitting golf balls like
it's no big deal you saw a light no
there's no light there's nothing
nothing's going on pay no attention go
along your business and the way they
open the episode with that weird creepy
song is just meant to highlight the
charade that the military is trying to
keep up like hey everything is normal
just go about your business repaint your
living rooms but on the number-4 madison
sneaks outside the fence and just finds
bodies lying everywhere people have been
executed all over the place regardless
of whether or not they're sick it also
kind of looks like some of these people
may have been in standoffs with the
military like they pulled guns in the
military people just shot him down
without asking questions so that in
addition to Daniels speech about what
happened in his childhood is just meant
to highlight what's going on outside the
safe zone and what's going on inside so
this episode is really about the
characters just opening their eyes to
the reality of the situation like things
are absolutely not normal at all
on to number three the creepy doctor
going around telling everybody about the
hospital that probably does not exist to
be fair though there probably is a
hospital in a nearby quarantine zone but
because the Daniel's speech it's pretty
clear that when [ __ ] hits the fan like
and people start turning inside these
quarantine zones because there are sick
people in the quarantine zones people
that are close to death then the
military is probably gonna execute
everyone like their prime not taking
people to death camps they probably do
intend to treat people but because we've
been watching the main show we know that
people turn into walkers whenever they
die and there
probably a lot of these people and these
quarantine zones that are close to death
so just explain Daniel's speech in his
home country what happened is there was
like some sort of military situation and
a bunch of people got rounded up taken
out and shot
but the military people were like don't
worry they'll be right back we're just
gonna go talk to them for a little while
so when daniel said as a boy he saw all
these bodies in the river it's like when
Madison is out on the streets looking at
all these dead bodies lying around it's
just a taste of things to come the
things that fear makes good men do and
it's also kind of what was going on with
Nick if you were curious about the big
WTF moment when he sabotaged that man's
morphine drip he was probably doing that
because he was afraid he was gonna hog
all the medicine or something like that
but he was gonna be a drain on the
SafeZone supplies speaking of which that
was also kind of the same thing going on
with Liza she was going around telling
the creepy doctor who all that sick
people were who the local drug addict
was on to number two things get a little
crazier the military comes in with guns
to their house takes Nick and Daniels
wife but does not let Daniel come
they're just like yeah we made some
promises nope not gonna happen
you stay here we're just taking these to
the things that happen in his childhood
that he tried to flee from it's all
happening again I think what's gonna
happen out especially since Liza went
with them is that we're gonna get a look
inside those quarantine camps we'll
actually see what's going on inside
there and yes they probably have doctors
they probably have some sort of hospital
situation but the minute that a couple
of those patients turned the military is
probably is gonna gun down everyone
without asking any questions so maybe
they'll use Sean hoto see here to help
get them out because he's their military
man on the inside if he didn't recognize
him he's actually an actor that was on
Southland with Michael Cudlitz who's
Abraham on the main show and with Ben
McKenzie who's on Gotham which is
actually coming back tonight so you see
it's all connected but he's actually a
pretty big character actor so I think
that he's gonna be back in next week's
episode and he's gonna be the person
that will help get the other people into
the quarantine zone or he'll be the one
to help Nick get out because I don't
think the Daniels wife is gonna make it
either way we have to get a look inside
those camps next week and finally on to
my number one WTF moment
Travis finally realizes what the light
is on the hill people are being executed
it's gunfire and no I don't think that
that's one of the quarantine camps where
that's happening I think it's just like
a random house that people are being
taken to it's just meant to hammer home
the point of what's really going on
despite
what the lieutenant says no we combed
every single house there's no one out
there not nothing to see nothing
nothing's happening don't ask me
questions about this again that
conversation actually happened
relatively early in the episode like the
minute that a person of authority
quickly dismisses something like that
that you clearly see like we saw it a
couple times then you know something's
up so here's a real big question for you
guys let me know in the comments how
long do you think it's gonna be inside
one of these quarantine zones before
people start turning in the military
flips out and starts gunning everyone
down inside picture like a large
airplane hangar with a bunch of sick
people all of a sudden one small corner
of it starts to turn and walkers start
spreading like wildfire it's like the
perfect storm you have a bunch of sick
people all in really close proximity to
each other packed in like sardines all
it takes is two or three of them to
start turning in they're all effed so if
you got a world war two death camp vibe
from this like Nazi death camp then you
are right on the mark people are being
taken to camps to be executed whether or
not that was their initial intention
that's definitely what's going to be
happening so in case you guys didn't
know there's only two more episodes of
fear The Walking Dead in season one then
we're gonna get Episode one of the main
show and it'll be just like normal I
don't think I'm gonna have time to make
a Walking Dead Q&A this week so I'll try
to answer all you guys questions in the
comments on this video so what I'm gonna
do is just keep the giveaway open this
week until I post my next fear The
Walking Dead video Gotham season 2
episode 1 is airing tonight so I'm gonna
do that video next I still need to do a
Doctor Who Q&A so I'll try to do that
after Gotham and I'm also doing a Doctor
Who giveaway so if you haven't watched
that Doctor Who video that I posted this
weekend just check that out there are a
bunch of TV shows starting this week so
just be sure to follow me on twitter and
facebook for updates on when videos are
posting while you guys wait for
everything you can click here to catch
up on Doctor Who if you guys haven't
seen my Doctor Who episode one video and
you can click here for all my other
Walking Dead videos thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight